all right tonight you're presenting you  can put you could say anybody's name  when you present you know that I should  say your name say my name say your name  and I win and then every come up I'm  running up and grab it all right I know  that's real but that that's like special  how much is that worth  look at these diamonds brain look at  this Oh real worth the passion and  energy that that means so much that you  don't want to know  I can intern who's your soup fight  that's it  gotcha my diamond shoes if you don't go  but those are diamonds on your shoes yes  the diamond shoes there's nothing fake  about Nick I love you Nick Nick hey let  me call some folks right now we about to  take those shoes  [Music]